[Music]
on this wednesday night
grounded the pandemic forces westjet to
slash
jobs and flights people have sort of
been panicked they're frightened
to do almost anything what's waiting in
the wings for an infected industry
the complications with contact tracing
and the labor
shortage in labs why the solution falls
short
plus the u.s president's plummeting
popularity in a battleground state
crucial for trump we're in north
carolina where
valuable votes are up for grabs and
tempers flare it's illegal you're
infringing on my
life the escalating fury over lobster
fishing
in nova scotia
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight
robin gill good evening and thank you
for joining us
covet 19 is creating more turbulence for
canada's air travel industry
westjet one of the biggest airlines in
this country says
fewer people are traveling so it's
unviable to continue
operating flights to much of atlantic
canada and a major city
in quebec as of november 2nd westjet
will indefinitely suspend all flights to
the three major airports in new
brunswick
as well as charlottetown pei and sydney
nova scotia
flights to quebec city will also be
suspended
and the airline will significantly
reduce service to st
john's and halifax all told more than a
hundred flights will be eliminated
this drastically limits the options for
people who need to travel to those
destinations
and as eric sorenson explains this is
another sign of trouble
in the skies a pandemic that has hurt
the economy
is just crushing the airline industry
westjet
cutbacks will further isolate the
atlantic provinces from each other and
from the rest of the country
cliff solnier has family down east it's
a little bit disappointing a little bit
hotter to
connect with our children and other
loved ones
it's not shocking news hardly anyone is
flying these days
since march westjet would normally have
carried more than 15 million passengers
over seven and a half months
instead they've transported just one
million during the pandemic
sadly we can no longer
maintain our full canadian network of
service
i'll ask you a few health-related
questions westjet says it has put
millions into making travel safe
but it doesn't help if no one's
traveling and a company that expanded
for decades is suddenly shrinking
over the last eight months we are
beginning to see
these efforts unravel some blame in part
the 14-day quarantine required of
travelers
the restrictions for travelers trying to
get in and out of
atlantic canada is is just asphyxiating
the
industry westjet is not alone struggling
to stay
airborne regional carrier porter
airlines already shut down
has delayed restarting now till december
air canada scored a bargain takeover of
air transat this week
the original price 18 dollars a share
slashed to five dollars
but air canada's second quarter saw 96
percent
fewer passengers than a year ago third
quarter results are coming soon and
could be dismal
as well what took our country's top
carriers
not years but decades to build and is
all going to unravel within a matter of
months it's going to be massive impacted
jobs
airline unions have called on ottawa to
inject billions of dollars to keep the
airlines afloat
obviously there's plenty of other
industries which also are crying out for
help
this analyst says the airline industry
may never fully recover in this country
business travel in particular is going
to be sharply hit because employers are
going to cut back on having their
employees
fly for work for now westjet is not
offering refunds on the canceled flights
it's giving credits for a service it
hopes will return to normal
someday eric sorensen global news
toronto
getting the airline business back on
track will require
a big change in the trajectory of this
pandemic
right now in many provinces case counts
are climbing
manitoba set a new daily record today
146 new cases
next door in saskatchewan there are 25
cases
further west alberta has 243 more cases
bc 158 out east new brunswick has eight
new cases quebec
844 and ontario 721
and in ontario more cases have been
linked to a major
outbreak at an indoor cycling studio in
hamilton
a total of 69 people have now tested
positive
46 are patrons and staff from the spinco
studio in downtown hamilton
the other 23 cases are secondary
infections
people who were infected by spinco
members
this is considered one of the largest
outbreaks at a fitness center in canada
what's particularly concerning
is the studio was found to be following
provincial guidelines designed to limit
the risk of coping 19.
ontario public health officials say
rules for fitness studios
are now under review even though they
followed guidelines there was obviously
significant transmission so i think we
do need to review the guidelines
and that's in process key to containing
the spread of kova 19
is contact tracing finding everyone who
may have been exposed
those efforts are the responsibility of
the provinces and territories
but the federal government has offered
its support now the prime minister is
asking
why regions haven't taken full advantage
of his government's offer
michael couture reports i'm going to
bring you into a room now
as public health agencies across the
country try to get ahead of the second
wave of covid19
prime minister justin trudeau says his
government is doing all it can to help
in an interview with cjob radio in
winnipeg
he says that federal money and manpower
is available
but in some cases he's waiting for
provinces to pick up the phone
we gave them 19 billion dollars uh over
the summer so that they could ramp up
their testing unfortunately not uh every
province has hit their uh
their the the agreed to targets in terms
of contact tracing we've made available
federal employees that
uh only are waiting for an ask from the
provincial governments
to come in and actually do more contact
racing must not be talking about ontario
because we're kicking everyone's butt on
testing
ontario premier doug ford proudly pushed
back on the prime minister's comments
but clearly contact racing was an issue
because ford also announced the hiring
of 600 more people we've hired 100 new
contact tracers this week alone
we'll have almost 4 000 boots on the
ground
supporting our contact tracing efforts
this fall
still ford's announcement and the prime
minister's comments
highlight the jurisdictional gap in this
pandemic well it does sound like a
frustrated
prime minister this former federal
health minister says trudeau
is dealing with the fallout of refusing
to use the emergency act
to take control of the response so you
now depend on the goodwill of the
premiers and the ministers of health
to get the stuff done leaving the
response as a regional responsibility
has allowed provinces to implement
targeted public health measures
but covid19 fatigue is becoming a
serious problem in certain regions
in alberta some aren't cooperating with
contact tracers
if we are not able to trace contacts and
prevent the virus from spreading
the impacts will continue to grow let's
hope that warning will get through to
people so that more drastic measures
like another forced lockdown
aren't necessary mike lacrouter global
news ottawa
ontario is doing a lot of testing but
the province is struggling
to process them right now there's a
backlog of more than 26
000 tests global news has learned the
province is launching
a rapid training program which could put
up to 600 workers into medical labs
that should help ease some of the strain
but as our chief investigative
correspondent carolyn jarvis reports
in this global news exclusive ontario
and the federal government have known
about the labor shortage
for years at the michener institute
labs that have been mostly dark during
the pandemic will soon be buzzing with
students
a fast track program two days online
followed by two hours in this lab
will start cranking out new workers to
address a labor shortage
we're looking to those who already have
a science background
in microbiology so these are learners
who already have a university degree
either at the baccalaureate or master's
level the program is funded by the
government of ontario
students who complete it will serve a
supporting roland labs
we built the platform to be able to
scale up by the end of november
upwards of about 600 learners but these
new auxiliary workers won't be able to
analyze results
that's the role of a technologist we
need qualified
licensed medical lab technologists who
actually perform the test
and all the labs are vying for the same
pool of
of individuals by some estimates ontario
is short
two to three hundred lab technologists
certified workers who complete a two to
four year program
dr tony mazzule's lab at toronto's mount
sinai hospital
needs 15 more of them now we're running
24 7 so it isn't just one shift we need
people to cover
um you know three different shifts seven
days a week and that's where it's
getting tight
people are coming out of retirement
while existing employees are putting in
overtime and foregoing vacation
for some the notion of a day off is
laughable
i think it was end of march or the
beginning of april
there's some days where it's only been
eight hours so i'm kind of happy about
that but
on average it's way more than that yeah
14 hours a day
the frustration for many is that it
didn't have to come to this
70 percent of labs in ontario were
understaffed prior to the pandemic
industry associations have been asking
governments for years
to increase the capacity of lab training
programs
and warning of a retirement drain in
ontario 50 percent can retire in the
next five years and many can retire now
the strain falls to the front line with
an unrelenting demand
at the door carolyn jarvis global news
toronto with the u.s presidential
election
just weeks away both candidates are
honing in
on the battleground state of north
carolina if donald trump's frequent
visits are assigned
the state is critical to his effort to
get reelected
it's big for democratic nominee joe
biden too
they're fighting for every single vote
because it's just
too close to call jackson prosko is in
north carolina tonight
with more jackson in fact robin this may
be the most important swing state in the
entire country
so important that tomorrow both
president donald trump
and joe biden's vp pick kamala harris
will be here at the same time with
competing events
and as you alluded to president trump
has been here eight
times since july that is an incredible
amount of presence
in this one state part of the reason why
it's so important is because things can
easily go either way
barack obama won this state in 2008 lost
it in 2012.
this time around the stakes are so much
higher and it's not a simple queso
for president trump yes he won it in
2016 but this time around the poll
suggests
he's in a very close fight perhaps even
behind joe biden
and the republican incumbent senator in
this state is also in a real fight for
his job
what really makes this state so
important though are its electoral
college votes joe biden would certainly
like to have them
donald trump absolutely needs them
crucial
for trump it would be nice
for biden if he had it but if he carries
north carolina
i don't think there is much doubt about
how the
electoral vote will come out jackson
north carolina
is being hit hard by the pandemic the
state is dealing with roughly 2
000 cases a day the worst it has ever
been how
is that weighing on voters you know like
everything to do with politics in this
country the pandemic has split along
ideological lines as well republican
voters we've been speaking to
say that nobody could have done a better
job managing this pandemic than
president trump
democrats on the other hand say that
literally anyone could have done a
better job than president trump has done
so that gives you a sense
of the split there that is not stopping
president trump though from
coming to the state to hold a large
rally here tomorrow thousands are
expected to gather
it's an outdoor venue there will be
temperature checks in place we should
point out and masks handed out
but as we've seen at these events
previously the masks are often ignored
and there is certainly no social
distancing one last note for you robin
the president's own approval ratings
both here in this state and across the
country
have all gone down in the wake of his
own covid19 positive diagnosis
jackson proskow in greenville north
carolina thanks jackson
this is what it looked like last night
in liverpool england
just hours before new coven 19
restrictions kicked in
dozens of people partied in the streets
after the bar shut down
they'll stay closed for four weeks
because the city is now under the
highest alert on the uk system of covet
19 restrictions
liverpool has had a rapid rise in
infections it has the third highest
number of covid19
hospital admissions in europe
france is also bringing in new measures
aimed at curbing the spread of the virus
starting saturday a curfew will be in
place in paris and several other cities
for at least four weeks anyone caught
breaking the nightly curfew will be
fined
france recorded more than 22 thousand
new cases today
it's also seeing a rapid rise of covet
19 patients
in hospital a dutch woman is believed to
be the first person to die
after getting coven 19 twice her case
was recently published in the oxford
university press
the 89 year old had a rare form of bone
cancer that compromised her immune
system
earlier this year she was admitted to
hospital where she tested positive for
the virus
but her symptoms subsided completely
nearly two months later
and two days after starting a new
chemotherapy treatment
the woman developed symptoms again and
tested positive for the virus
she died two weeks later scientists say
the genetic makeup of the virus was
different each time
making it likely she was re-infected
speeding through space coming up the
historic flight for russia's rocket
plus the big blast involving a relic
from the second world war
[Music]
it's the end of an era for the last time
nasa paid russia's space agency to fly
an american astronaut on board a soyuz
rocket
to the international space station and
that rocket set a speedy record arriving
at the space station just three hours
and three minutes
after liftoff in 2011 the u.s space
agency retired its shuttle program so it
was entirely dependent on purchasing
rides from russia
in a few weeks nasa will turn to spacex
founded by elon musk
to launch crews to the iss on the dragon
spacecraft
but look at this look at them take this
look at this
still ahead the fury over lobster
fishing in nova scotia
the largest unexploded bomb from the
second world war has detonated safely
during delicate efforts to defuse it in
poland navy specialists were trying to
neutralize the five-ton
tall boy remotely when it went off the
bomb was discovered last year in a
waterway with only its nose exposed
it was dropped by britain's royal air
force in an attack on a german cruiser
in 1945.
it missed the target and sank
tensions are flaring around nova
scotia's lobster fishery
at issue is the rights of indigenous
lobster harvesters
to fish outside the commercial season
rights that are protected
by supreme court of canada ruling as
ross lord reports the violence is
unfolding despite weeks of negotiations
aimed at finding common ground
threats and violence are intensifying in
the nova scotia lobster fishery
the cops can't even control these guys
and there's a lot of them an estimated
200 commercial fishers
preventing employees of a lobster
holding pound from leaving
and removing crates of lobster caught by
indigenous harvesters
put them down what are you doing don't
touch it this is ours
indigenous fisher jason maher says he
barricaded himself
inside the pound fearing for his life
and then the rcmp
came and told us that the only way that
this was going to come to any kind of
end
was if i hand over my lobsters to them
and i leave when they said that i said
no i'm not doing that
one month after the sebagon agony first
nation issued licenses to fishers
for a self-regulated fishery their
commercial counterparts insist
no one should fish outside of the normal
season
that's all we want protesters blocked
access to a news conference
planned by the sebagon aggety chief some
threatening a global news crew
with violence forcing them to leave the
group that represents many of the
commercial fissures
says it had nothing to do with the
violent protests
that's not the path forward here as
canadians we should all expect that the
path forward
is through dialogue assembly of first
nations national chief perry belgaard
says he's appalled a sentiment echoed by
fisheries minister bernadette jordan
in a statement jordan says progress
cannot be made if individuals resort to
violence
but the chief of sebag and eggetty
suggests the lack of trust
extends to the government the government
does not take us
respect us on a nation or nation level
which they should
and you know when they do so that will
be victory for us
in the meantime rcmp say they're
investigating threats
mischief and property damage they've
brought in extra members to ease
tensions
before worst damage is done ross lord
global news
up next from reality tv to documentary
donald trump starts in a new film
focused on pandemic
failures
a new documentary details how the trump
administration responded to covet 19.
it highlights the misjudgment the missed
opportunities
and how the white house is scrambling
behind the scenes
here's mike trolley hello everyone there
was consensus in the pandemic chaos
in early march over the past few days
we've seen covet 19 spread around the
world
world leaders mostly followed the same
script
locking down major cities on the advice
of doctors and scientists
as the infected were quarantined in
hospitals it's in that context the
documentary
totally under control examines a u.s
response
that was anything but whatever happens
we're totally prepared
you know i think in the early days it
felt like we're like oh
this is this unprecedented virus we've
never seen anything like it before
we don't know how it's going to respond
it's just not true there were
experts who didn't know exactly how it
was you know going to unfold and they
predicted it
and their warnings were ignored for
months the documentary's three directors
kept their work a secret
so as not to scare off potential
whistleblowers it is
time to lay our careers on the line
and push back they focused on those
crucial early months when
an already culturally fractured united
states was desperate for leadership
but instead got platitudes and politics
it would be wonderful it'll be a gift
from
heaven complete [ __ ]
he has no idea what he's talking about
and that's kind of the tragedy of the
story
is that all of their skill all of their
dedication to public health
was undermined and upended by an
administration
that simply wanted to put politics above
everything the film's release less than
three weeks before the u.s election
is no coincidence it's meant to be a
report card for the trump administration
and while it will no doubt be championed
by the left and derided as fake news by
the right
there's no denying not enough is being
done in the u.s
to slow the spread of covet 19. but the
big problem now is that there's no plan
there's no coordinated federal plan in
order to deal with it properly there's
just
the purposeful absence of a plan how
many americans agree with that
we'll find out on november 3rd
microlight global news toronto
and that is global national for this
wednesday i'm robin gill
tonight we leave you with mars reaching
opposition to the sun and the closest
point
to earth that
[Music]
you